we're seeing henry ruggs in court for
the first time in months the former
raider appeared before a judge earlier
today let's head over to victoria saha
she joins us live in studio with the
crucial piece of evidence the judge
wants to keep in the deadly dui crash
case there are two factors that have
been crucial parts in this case how fast
ruggs was driving and the alcohol in his
system today his attorney david chesnov
tried to convince the judge to toss out
the blood work evidence
former raiders player henry ruggs iii
stood by his lawyer david chestnut
tuesday morning as he presented to the
judge why the search warrant in the
early morning hours after the november
second crash should be dismissed that
search warrant was approved by a judge
to get a blood test to see how much
alcohol was in drugs system according to
prosecutors ruggs's blood alcohol level
was two times the legal limit when he
was driving 156 miles per hour seconds
before he caused the fiery crash on
tuesday his attorney tried to convince
the judge to toss out the blood alcohol
evidence because he believes it was
taken without probable cause the officer
knew he didn't have enough
and asked not what to do and the
sergeant said don't worry about probable
cause just say there was driving
behavior in a fatality the judge
disagreed is saying when being
questioned by officers ruggs told them
quote he was on his way home from home
after the passenger in his car his
girlfriend told officers they were at
topgolf earlier and had drinks under the
totality of circumstances there is more
than sufficient evidence for a finding
of probable cause a comment that home to
home
is equally consistent
your honor with
being the victim of an being in an
accident
and
suffering head injuries the fiery crash
took the life of 23 year-old tina tinter
and her dog max ruggs faces felony
charges of dui causing death and
reckless driving
i have been in contact with tantor's
family since this tragedy they were in
court today but they declined to comment
on what unfolded ruggs continues to be
on a high level of electronic monitoring
he'll be back in court in september for
a preliminary hearing to decide if there
is enough evidence to send his case to
trial kirsten thank you victoria